is now a good time to invest in property
is now the time to buy it's 2022 we've
seen a massive boom over the last couple
of years prices have been soaring now
they've sort of slowed down a little bit
the market's still hot but should you
buy now or should you wait for the crash
should you wait for a dip or a
correction and buy cheaper well my name
is samuel leeds i've been investing in
property now for 14 years i've seen two
recessions i've made millions of pounds
in property i'm gonna give my honest
thoughts and opinion about is now a good
time to buy in the uk or should you wait
so the first thing i want to say to you
right now if you're wondering should
should i invest my money into a house
should i invest my money to properties
well what's the other alternative
okay if you're not going to invest in
property let's say you've got 100 000
pounds and you think oh should i wait
well
what do you do in the meantime leave it
in your bank because i tell you
something that inflation is going up
like crazy so if you leave your money in
the bank while you wait your money's
shrinking so i'd much rather any day of
the week have it in bricks and mortar
and land and property that's going to
hold its value that's going to pay me
rent then leave it in the bank maybe you
want to invest it in um on a
cryptocurrency okay cool well
cryptocurrencies absolutely crashed over
the last what three six months bitcoin
was about fifty thousand now it's at
twenty thousand
so
is crypto currency is cryptocurrency
safe right now maybe maybe in business i
guess it depends on the business so
there's always a reason to find there's
always there's always reasons that you
can say why now's not a good time in
anything whether it be business gold
silver bitcoin crypto
bank index fund stocks there's always
people can always find reasons why to
invest and people can always find
reasons why to not invest my opinion is
firstly i don't think there's going to
be a massive crash i don't think it's
going to happen now eventually there'll
be a crash in the market because they're
always this eventual soon there might be
a dip because after after an expansion
always comes a correction and then after
a dip comes another boom
the reason i think property is the
safest investment and the reason i right
now i'm actively buying properties i've
bought 48 houses in the last six months
so i'm actively buying stuff and the
reason is because number one
property gives you rent
even if you buy a property and it goes
down in value who cares because if
you're renting it out
then you just wait for it to go back up
it's not like you're buying something
and then you're relying on it going up
in six months you're buying some if
you're buying a property and you're a
smart property investor you're not
buying it for the capital appreciation
you're buying it for the income it's
like a golden goose it's laying you eggs
every morning the eggs are the rent and
the eggs you eat and the rent you use to
pay your bills so if the property if the
piece of real estate that you've got is
giving you rent
why do you care if it goes up or down in
the next six months it doesn't actually
matter so that's the first thing make
sure it's giving you rent secondly if
you're buying property
right now in the uk and you're worried
about there being a dip
you can you can control
the economy of your investment what do i
mean by that
if you're worried that the the market's
going to go down and your property's
going to go down there's things that you
can do to massively increase the value
of your property for example you can buy
a property below market value
if if you think the market's going to go
down and the house is 200 grand and you
buy it for 180 if it goes down
you've actually not lost out because you
bought it cheap in the first place or
you can buy it and do do something to it
to push the value up
for example
you could buy it and turn it into four
houses buy a big house and split it into
four apartments
increase the value by 25
and suddenly
if there's a dip
well you've increased the value so
my thoughts are buy property smart
someone once said don't wait to buy
property buy property and wait and i
don't think that could be more apt i
think if you want to invest in property
just make sure that you do it right
property prices as i said before they go
up down up down up down up down but on
average
properties double in value every 10
years
and people get all upset with me when i
say this and say that's not going to
happen over the next 10 well that's what
they said 10 years ago and what's
happened over the last 10 they've
doubled and what about the 10 before
that doubled and what about the 10
before that doubled despite brexit
despite the 2008 crash now i'm not
saying the properties are guaranteed to
double in the next 10 years but what i
am saying is with the cost of inflation
as everything's going up your money's
shrinking
real estate and land holds its value so
my thoughts are
don't wait to buy buy now
but buy the right thing
that at the right price
that you can force the value up and that
will give you rent and if you learn to
do that no matter what the season is no
matter what the economy's economy is
doing you'll create your own economy and
get rich and property certainly served
me for the last 14 years that's my
opinion i'd love to know your opinions
comment below i'll read all the comments
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you